[Music]
crowds of people in london's
china town here to get a no questions
asked
kovid jab without an appointment or id
and public enthusiasm for getting jabs
what ministers desperate to see
as they warn of the indian variant
taking over
the latest estimates are that more than
half
and potentially as many as three
quarters
of all new cases are now of this variant
if you just look at the pure data which
is out today uh it looks
quite worrying so we had 3535 cases of
the
uh of the um 617.2
uh last week and we have uh just about
double that 6959 now
but we are not so where does that leave
freedom day on june the 21st
i think it is really really just on the
cusp at the moment
troubling signs about the variant not
the only thing weighing on the health
secretary
accused of being incompetent and a liar
by dominic cummings this week
mr hancock at the dispatch box to repair
his bruised reputation
these unsubstantiated allegations around
honesty
are not true and that i've been straight
with people
in public and in private throughout one
of dominic cummings chief interrogators
come into his colleagues defense serious
allegations were made we asked for
evidence
to be provided and until such evidence
is provided
those allegations should be treated as
unproven
but away from the commons in colchester
the pm
not offering mr hancock public support
the right person to be doing what we're
doing now do you have confidence in that
what we're doing now
is trying obviously to protect all
residents in
in all care homes but what happened in
care homes at the beginning of this
pandemic
did you make the statement in march that
they would be
tested before going back to care homes
and that didn't turn out to be true
because you didn't have the testing
system
in place is that what really happened no
i
look there there will be a time when we
go back over all this in great detail
but my recollection of events
is that i committed to delivering
that testing for people going from
hospital into care homes
when we could do it no outright denial
then that mr hancock had given
assurances to number 10
people would be tested before being
discharged
sending people back to care homes
untested
did happen during april and is that your
biggest regret in this pandemic
because we didn't have the testing
capacity at the start of the pandemic
it wasn't possible mr hancock said
there'll come a time to go over
all of this in great detail just not
today
but be it the mistakes of the past or
concerns for the future
there's no escape from the pressure of
this virus or
its unpredictability beth rigby sky news